so we talked about this a bunch but it
seems to me that President Obama wants
it every which way on marijuana in
December he did something pretty good he
basically told the Justice Department
that the feds will no longer get
involved with the states rights related
to medical marijuana ok that's pretty
solid then just a couple days ago he had
the Department of Justice filed a
defense of marijuana's classification as
a Schedule one drug that is the same
classification that heroin has we've got
a statement from the assistant attorney
general this is Gregory Broderick he
said this psychoactive addictive drug is
not accepted as safe for medical use at
this time even with medical supervision
so you really need to kind of wrap your
brain around what's going on here the
states are passing this thing one at a
time it's happening just like a marriage
it's all good there are people that have
cancer and AIDS and all kinds of other
diseases that are using this for
medicinal purposes and they're not
having all the horrible side effects
that all the big pharma drugs are giving
them then Obama's on one hand saying ok
the feds aren't going to get involved
and then on the other hand is saying the
complete reverse what that quote is the
complete reverse of what the actual
facts and science are I really don't
understand this about President Obama
and I think this is something where he
is failed epically actually because it's
such terrible mixed messaging please
explain to me what he's up to you well
what he's up to is hopefully is that
thing that your parents do or your your
like he's like don't you know I'm gonna
say this but like when it's just us
hanging out that I'll tell you what I
really feel so it in turns to the camera
go we at the federal government believe
that marijuana is terrible for reasons
of probably elections and voting okay
cut alright so if you want to smoke weed
smoke weed just don't get caught that's
what it is
and I get it and that's what he did with
gay marriage before he came around with
gay marriage because everyone knew he
was okay with it
awkward but this is completely backwards
can we just throw the quote up for one
more second because it's really
important to understand what he's having
his people say this psychoactive
addictive drug is not accepted as safe
medical use at this time even with
medical supervision I mean I know people
that are using marijuana for medical
reasons and also I know plenty of people
that smoke pot I've never truly never
him because someone is welcome to
correct me in the comment section I've
never seen someone addicted to pot now
George Carlin used to do something about
how you know one day most people that
smoke pot they're like all right I'm
done smoking pot and they stop smoking
pot or they're like you know what I
smoke pot every day now I'm gonna smoke
it once a month and so what I just don't
get so what is it this is about votes
because the votes are showing that most
people actually at this point are okay
with medical marijuana so what is he up
to lobbying interests I mean the article
you gave me was I think equivocating of
marijuana to heroin well that's what the
Schedule one classification that's what
they're doing aren't prostituting
themselves over pot and quitting their
jobs and losing their families and
ravaging their health and their
appearances it's it's I am Doritos but
just be very clear that's not from the
yeah but just be very clear that's not
from the article that I'm sending you
that's the way the government is
classifying it so that's the government
yeah it's so weird well if this is
there's other ways to interpret this
because there a lot of people were
trying to get into the medicinal
marijuana growing industry yeah and the
recreational drug industry like people
in Colorado and in Washington the
problem is like for them they're like
yeah we're allowed to grow it we're
allowed to sell it the money we get from
it we can't put in banks because of all
the federal laws right all of that it
still can be construed in the opposite
way which is Obama is telling us that
it's okay for the states do what you
want but there's another way to
interpret it where it's like he's
telling us that but he's still trying to
end medicinal marijuana use and
recreational drug use a bad way getting
him at the bank's right precisely so
that quote right there is a direct
attack on medicinal marijuana so he's
pretending that he's being cool with
marijuana not just the recreational side
but he's actually attacking the
medicinal side and that's the part that
I just simply don't understand honestly
I think that's a way to win the battle
against Obama is just kind of be like
guilt him into being like I thought we
were cool buddy you know and she'd be
like you used to be the cool dad and now
you're being kind of a dick so is truly
what's going on here that Big Pharma
which obviously gives a lot of money to
politicians and nobody's above being
bought and even as a second term
president with only two years left that
he still
at the whim of people that have given
him a lot of money and since there isn't
big money yet behind weed I think there
will be and especially as it gets passed
more recreationally and eventually
Starbucks or somebody's gonna come in
and you're gonna be able to get weed in
it at a chain store but until then the
politicians leap from behind the other
way I mean look at look at heroin right
heroin is classified as a class schedule
which is like I mean try to keep to a
schedule after you've done heroin right
but the but but then you can still get
morphine morphine as a pharmaceutical
version of it that's okay sorry by
saying medicinal marijuana maybe he's
distinguishing from whatever synthetic
you know THC derivative is gonna be sold
by Eli Lilly and Merck and the people
who are paying for that statement to get
right all right so final thought on this
you don't smoke weed right no do you
fear weed no and you fear that someone
that is sick that is smoking weed to
help themselves that that's somehow
gonna fringe on your personal rights or
destroy your life well this segment is
ending right there there you see what
you did
[Music]